I want to talk about see here dimensions
today and of course this is pretty
serious business there's five major
dimensions there's many others but
there's five major ones
all of them preventable all of them
reversible okay and of course there are
presidential candidates out there who
say that these diseases have no known
cause no known treatment no known cure
that's all nonsense but oh yeah they
also said we're gonna raise two million
dollars to support people doing the
research on these dimensions so we can
get to the bottom of this okay anyway
here on once you get a hold of the book
epigenetics the death of a genetic
series is a transmission the DVD
somebody needs to go to jail and then
the CD public enemy number one it goes
into some detail here and everything I'm
going to share with you now let's start
out with vast your dementia very common
vascular dementia the arteries in the
brain get plugged up by the same stuff
that plugs up your arteries in your
heart your kidneys okay your neck in
your eyes and it's called inflammation
eating fried foods processed meats oils
gluten anything inflammatory is going to
set your arteries up for being clogged
with scar tissue not not cholesterol
plaque as was theorized before uh-uh no
no actually the clogging is caused by
scar tissue generated by the lining of
your arteries response to inflammation
caused by trans fat settles like amines
and acrylamide all of which are found in
fried foods processed meats or nitrates
and nitrites things like deli slices
sandwich meats sausage ham bacon Bologna
salami that kind of stuff and then of
course oils microwave popcorn theater
popcorn olive oil coconut oil margins
mayonnaise undressing cooking oils and
gluten wheat brother and oats then we'll
talk about the nutritional approach here
in a second and then we have Alzheimer's
disease
Allisyn disease has nothing to genetics
it certainly has this thing to do with
aluminum
Allisyn disease is a physician cause
disease is caused because doctors
demonized cholesterol okay to sell a
product called Crisco the Procter &
Gamble gave the American Heart
Association
1.7 million dollars 1952 dazeem in eyes
cholesterol so they could sell Crisco
means they meaning the Procter & Gamble
and it was the whole thing over
cholesterol as a sales campaign well it
turns out when you lower your
cholesterol and your brain is seventy
five percent by weight the white matter
of the brain is the myelin the
insulation material the brain is 100
percent cholesterol so you get on a
closer fictive diet so you can sell
Crisco and you get on Cluster lowering
drugs just because the pharmaceutical
company says hey if you want your
cholesterol Lord will make a drug for it
they were just opportunistic they're
right and then let's see here we have
Korsakoff syndrome which is a deficiency
of a single vitamin wernicke Korsakoff
syndrome which is an efficiency of a
single vitamin and a MS multiple
sclerosis at the same time and then
vitamin b3 g vitamin b12 vitamin b12
deficiency and dementia which is
self-explanatory so I like to cover mall
one healthy brain and heart attack 400
pounds of body weight three of the D
stress capsules twice a day 400 pounds
of body weight - twice - a day one of
breakfast one at dinner time of the
ultimate cardio sticks to support
healthy blood pressure and support
healthy blood flows for obstructed or
reason and also the ultimate daily
tablets three of those twice is one by
one month to support healthy blood flow
through the structure or a reason and
let's see here oh yeah we already talked
about the defense has but I would also
throw in one more thing and that would
be the because of the Warnecke course
cause we gotta deal with the MS and the
wernicke course cost it would be the UM
it would be the ultimate let's see here
ultimate cardio sticks no I would go
with a BTT 2.0 tablets the VTT 2.0
tablets and I'd take two of those twice
a day that's one one bottle a month of
those per hundred pounds of body weight
and all that's designed to support
remote maintance repair
of the neurological system right oh yeah
and you have to eat about 10 to 12 eggs
a day per 100 pounds of body weight
either poached soft yolk soft-boiled
soft yolk soft soft scramble and butter
and again all of this is in the book
epigenetics the death of the genetic
theory disease transmission the DVD
somebody needs to go to jail in the
seedy public enemy number one there's a
double-blind randomized study on
Alzheimer disease which shows very
clearly that you can prevent Alliser
disease by 78% was a supplement program
okay can prevent and it's very minor
supplement they only use 2 nutrients
plus a certain lifestyle the people who
they gave it to we're talking about
5,000 people 2,500 on the supplement
program and 2,500 on the dummy pill and
the ones getting the supplement program
reduce the risk of al-noor disease
compared to the ones getting the dummy
pill by 78% that is a pre you know that
is a prevention okay and then when you
have advanced Alzheimers ages taking
large doses of a single vitamin got rid
of significant amount of the clinical
symptoms so you can be functional that
came out in 1992 that's one of the
reasons why my debt doctors don't lie
audio cassette tape was so controversial
and so interesting to people okay again
I want you to get a hold of that book
epigenetics for death of the genetic
disease transmission the DVD somebody
needs to go to jail and the CD public
enemy number one and stick with us
because we're going back with more truth
justice and a young give anyway